what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
the 14th of july listen the joint
is brought to you by blue chew blue chew
is an online service that delivers the
same
active ingredients at viagra and cyalis
at a fraction of the cost you could take
it any time
day or night and the process is simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com talk to one
of the licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you receive
you'll receive your prescription
within days the best part it's all
online
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations
and no waiting online at the pharmacy so
if you could benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
get down with mama
blue chew can help and they got a
special deal for you today
try blue chew for free what are you
talking about joey free
free with promo code joey on a [__]
wednesday morning just pay five dollars
for shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code joey to
receive your first month
for free and as always i want to thank
bluechu
for sponsoring the joint let me tell you
something you can't take a chance it's
summertime
you bump into a freak you want to be
prepared you want to have all your
[__] missiles in action
so go to buchu.com right now
and then to code joey to receive your
first month
for free the joint is also brought to
you by
on it on it is the [__] goods whether
it's shroom tech
alpha brain the protein bites
the virgil tech listen they don't stop
and now
they came out with on it black label
alpha brain this is tremendous it's a
premium
member it's reef refined formula that
promotes speed
and focus for extreme productivity
that's what you're looking for that's
what you'll get my doctor friend up in
minneapolis
ally told me she was on it and she was
buzzing
i can't wait to start my next cycle of
alpha brain i'm gonna go with
the black label and you too you're
slipping
just like me go to honor.com right now
take a look
at what they've got they've come a long
[__] way and they were great to start
off with you still get 100 money-back
guarantee
if the alpha brain doesn't work for you
so you got nothing to [__] lose with
black label
still got the same guarantee and it's
going to rock your world even more
so go to honor.com right now and take a
look it could be blue
it could be the alpha brain it could be
the shroom tech sport
the shroom tech immune it could be the
protein powder
it could be the ect i mean they have so
many products
that's going to blow your mind i can't
do nothing for you on the club bells and
the
kettlebells but as far as supplements
are concerned
i got you go to honor preston joey your
church
and get 10 off your order delivered
right to your [__] house
go to honor.com right now and press in
joey or church and get 10 percent
delivered to your house
who else does it like that nobody and
100 percent money back guarantee on
alpha brain
and you could keep the [__] product
who does that nobody
that's why i'm telling you to go to
honor.com
let's start this [__] joint up
on a wednesday
it's a beautiful day to be alive the
14th
of the month
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 14th
of july for starters i'm sorry about
monday's podcast
we had a tape a little early on [__]
saturday because sunday i had plans
monday i was getting [__] mouth
surgery so
uh we didn't cover the [__] ufc so we
will do it today
i hope you had a good couple of [__]
days i did have the surgery on monday
on my gums i got stitches on the bottom
and on the [__] top
tremendous when you get stitches in your
mouth uh
the feeling is uh the [__] needles
were enough he put the [__] liquid
cocaine on there but he only sat me
there for like two [__] minutes
and also things i just started getting
[__] needles to the mouth
they were coming out of everywhere i
couldn't even [__] control them i had
earphones on i had my eyes closed and i
kept feeling them
the needle at the top of the [__]
mouth was the one that killed me that
one
i never got a knee on the roof of my
[__] mouth that one put me in never
never land
even the [__] nurses like jesus
christ i came home
last night i [__] uh took one [__]
pain pill and i'm like this ain't for
[__] me this ain't for me no more
so i got rid of him i just did the
regular [__] ibuprofen 800
and they gave me some [__] to gargle
with and i'm back [__]
i'm back like a [__] savage it's kind
of weird
it doesn't hurt at all it just it feels
like
i got a piece of chicken in the top you
ever eat like meat you don't brush your
[__] teeth
it feels like your teeth get all [__]
up that's what i have so
we'll [__] live but i wanted to talk
to you about
ufc 264 or 246.
i have no [__] idea what numbers to
even look at anymore i don't know what
they are
all i know it's saturday's [__] ufc
on the gambling front i did okay i did
two out of three i had gilbert burns
for the big night and i had a small bet
on dustin and i had 1.5
on the over thanks to draftkings i told
you [__]
to take the [__] i i [__] put it
up on instagram
and on [__] twitter before the fight
for a dollar you could win 264 with a
first round knockout
some of you did it some of you just told
me to go [__] myself now go [__]
yourself
you missed out on 264 dollars even if
you weren't gonna gamble again
one dollar would have won your 260
[__] four that's tremendous
that's a great night i wish i could have
done it but i'm part of [__]
draftkings
so they won't let me do it but that's
that's why i put that move up
for you guys i listen i was hoping that
the fight went [__] over i wanted to
you know i wanted to win on the over but
then i realized that for what i bet i
was only going to win 22 [__] dollars
boo hoo
who gives a [__] i would have rather win
264 dollars but
that's the reason why i posted it what i
want to talk to you about
again again was the performance
by conor mcgregor we
like i said i put a small bet on dustin
because i thought connor was gonna come
in [__] in the hands of blazing
and i gotta tell you was i [__] wrong
you know
i didn't like him enough to bet on him
but he's still a
a deadly [__] fighter he's still an
aggressive fight he's still [__]
great as far as i'm concerned
i wasn't gonna write him off that way
unless
if i thought that [__] dustin would
beat him that decisively
i would have [__] bet ten thousand on
it or something [__] gone over my
head
but i i thought connor was gonna you
know come back
do what he did for nate diaz look at the
tape and see where his shortcomings were
but
obviously not and then we had to start
with the [__] excuses that
you know he broke his ankle and training
or he hurt himself in training
a couple weeks ago nothing bothers me
more as [__] you know you lost
you lost you know he didn't look that
good
um but what we're going to talk about
today
is what happened afterward that like i
was telling we have a guest today we're
gonna have my man george on here
from mma junkie and uh
we were talking on the phone after the
fights on sunday
you know i was telling him i go you know
that interview with rogan and him on the
mat
and what he was saying and what he was
saying leading up to the fight
was not good it just wasn't good i
thought that uh
i thought that when i saw the whole
picture
it disturbed me a little bit i mean
after the
after rogan interviewed him and he was
on his back and
he was saying and listen you know me dog
i [__] said things to people's wives
i'll tell you why
because i read the roberto duran book
and before he fought sugar ray leonard
he bumped into him on the street and
told me he was gonna [__] his wife in
the ass
sugar ray got all [__] confused and
that's why sugar
ray lost the first fight because duran
[__] with his head
when i've done it it's the [__] with
people's head but
that behavior reminded me also
of me when i was on coke that's
you know i've heard rumors i'm not
saying dustin
uh dustin connor is on coke i'm not
saying that
i i've heard rumors and [__] like that i
don't know if that's true and then none
of my [__] business
but that behavior was kind of weird and
i've seen that behavior before i've seen
that behavior in myself
you know when i was going through my
divorce
when i was uh unhappy when i was unsure
of myself
you know i i've acted in that manner so
that's why it was disturbing to me
because he's one of the best athletes in
the [__] world
and for him to act that way and all
right he was on the mat
and he was in pain and he was
disillusioned
and he was hurt so that's fine i i get
all that you know i've been in
when after [__] surgeries you got to
see me i'm not the nicest person in the
world either
but then he woke up from the [__]
surgery and it continued
on the dust emporia thing and his wife
and that's where i see the problem you
know and let me tell you something i've
had
a thousand problems so when i see
somebody acting
in that manner i [__] right away i go
maybe it's drugs maybe it's something
that's going on maybe
it's the pressure of fighting i mean
listen man can you imagine being him
having a hundred million two hundred
million dollars having a whiskey
business
and then having to go get [__]
punched in the face it's
listen once you have all that money it's
rough
to go in and smell [__] feet again
and
do [__] sit-ups and [__] push-ups
in the [__] stinky gym
and you know it's kind of [__] tough
man
so i get it you know i mean the guys on
the mat
with a broken [__] leg and dana white
is already
making the poirier fight you know
that's not [__] fair that let the guy
go home
obviously you see the guy is a shell of
who he was
the last three fights we've seen him uh
it's been a [__] horror show
you know yeah he beat cowboy cerrone
listen
cowboy's a dear friend of mine i love
him to death
but even cowboy will tell you he's not
the cowboy of both
if he would have fought the cowboy of
old it would have been [__] lights
out also
and i know a lot of years of disagree i
know a lot of years that'll say
yeah maybe but let's talk the truth here
you know i mean
uh something's not right
something isn't right i don't know if
it's the pressure i don't know if he
should just
retire like you're gonna hear you know
this is a year injury you just don't
come back from this
in six months unless you're [__]
superhuman
you know i mean i've had it's been six
months since my [__] surgery
and i still feel it i mean i'm not a
fighter i've kicked under the water i've
kicked the bag a few times
that's your foot you got to walk you got
to kick you got to wrestle on it so it's
going to take time you got to strengthen
that thing you got to
do squats you got to start from scratch
so i hope that this will give him a
chance to
look you know this will be his [__]
covid
this will be his little [__] breather
look within
and see what the [__] he wants to do you
know listen if you don't want to fight
no more don't fight
but it's a lot better than taking a beat
and breaking your leg you know you were
talking about
putting the kid in the [__] stretcher
and then turned they carried you out on
the stretcher
so that's that's what happens it's it's
a
[__] up [__] life and you
got to be careful what you say to people
listen i'm 58 i learned the hard way
i got a big [__] mouth i like to yell
and scream i've gotten into arguments
you know when you say something negative
like that you're leaving yourself open
it's like throwing a [__] jab when
you throw a jab you gotta you gotta know
that you're open somewhere
now you just open yourself up so when
you wish something like that on somebody
when you you know say that to somebody
you really gotta [__] think
that this could happen to you you know i
had a thousand anecdotes
about covid you know i i i still think a
thousand [__] things about covert
you know why i don't say him because i
might get it look at ted nugent he was
talking [__]
[__] covet and next thing you know
he's [__] coughing and sneezing
he's like this ain't no joke that's what
happens you know if you leave yourself
open and you throw a punch or something
you're [__] open so i just want to
like i
listen man i look at conor mcgregor
and i look at what i'm going through now
and i
i tell you at 32 years old you think
you're [__] a wise guy i
i doug i thought i knew everything at
32. you don't know
[__] you really don't know [__] at 32.
you're just getting your [__] groove
i didn't know anything until my [__]
40s and now
at 58 i could look at the field and go
wow i could see the whole [__] field
i feel like joe montana i could see the
whole field i feel like tom brady
i could see a hundred yards i could see
the move before it happens
and that's why they always ask older
people what would you tell younger
people
if you could [__] do it again you
know that what do you think they ask
them
like i look at connor's situation as a
58 year old
and i go listen go home get healthy
invest your money and sell [__]
whiskey don't worry about fighting for
now
go do go be with your family go get
healthy
don't take calls from dana white don't
take calls from [__] nobody not your
agent you don't need to
you don't need to you're swimming in
[__] dog why are you taking calls
from these people
so they can [__] push into something
you don't want to [__] do
listen he's got to just take some time
reflect
and see what the [__] he really wants to
do with his life
i don't think he wants to fight anymore
you know that type of money
i mean you do your best work when you
got a gun to your [__] head you know
and
it's a lot of pressure guys it's a lot
of pressure
he just you know rogan and dave
chappelle went out and sold out
two shows at the mgm grand i'm very
[__] proud of him that is [__]
sensational
conor mcgregor sells out a city
do you know how hard that is to do and
he just does it naturally he just sells
out a [__] city everybody prospers
when he's in [__] town
the airport i mean you know you're gonna
he i didn't even know garth brooks was
in town with [__] i don't know how
many tickets
i mean conor mcgregor is no [__] joke
so yeah
everybody's got a bunch of [__]
vampires hanging around them
you we don't see it because we're not in
his [__] personal life
but you i could just imagine i know what
i went through as a comic
and i know he's he kicks it up six
[__] notches up in the [__]
millions
so can you imagine the pressure he's got
on him the pressure that people put on
him
it's it's a [__] nightmare so he's
got to
sit think and see
what he wants to do and what his next
move is you know
and whatever it is god bless him you
know it's his [__] life
that's what us as fans we always we're
so selfish as fans
we're selfish in every aspect of our
life but we're selfish as fans you know
somebody wraps it up or whatever we get
kind of now that they have lives they
have thoughts they have their own soul
you have to look at them and go [__]
this is it you know hopefully he'll come
back
you know and he'll come back 20 times
better
and 20 times stronger he'll be 33 years
old
maybe 34 years old so
you got to see where the [__] they're at
today i had george
from mma junkie join us via [__] zoom
i hope you [__] enjoy it i'll
see you afterwards stay black hold enjoy
george remember my junkie
[Music]
what's happening brother
how are you my friend good than you
not bad feeling good got some stitches
in my mouth but [__] it we'll make it
work you know what i'm saying
what happened you hit with an uppercut
or something no
i had to go if my gums are [__] up so
they were a little swollen
this had been going on for like three
[__] months
maybe four months i went back to la and
tried to get them fixed
but they didn't take she had to do some
work and
i'm not going back to la to fix them now
some i just got the gums done here
i feel better today i only required one
pain pill the rest was [__]
uh that motrin 800 i didn't want to go
back on the pain pills again after the
knee surgery
but i want to talk to you about three
fights how you doing today big george
doing great uh last week was [__] a
whirlwind you know here in vegas
not only the event itself but people
coming out
like you know just coming out for the
first time in 18 months so people just
want to let their hair down
mma people friends and family it all
came together you had garth brooks 80
0001 stadium mcgregor empoyer in the
arena that's another 20 000 so imagine
what the strip was like
wow so garth brooks sold 80 000 tickets
and then in the new stadium yeah holy
holy [__]
garth is still that [__] big
yeah i guess so i i don't follow country
too much but i mean i know the name
and uh it had been sold out for a while
so yeah he didn't have a problem with 80
000 either
yeah i saw a couple guys went and posted
stuff up from uh
from watching him i didn't know he was
in vegas though
i saw a couple of videos at garth brooks
that people had gone
but let's talk about saturday night
let's start we're going to talk about
three fights let's start with the
the first fight of the night that suge
man against that crazy little italian
[__] from boston
who you you have to hit him with a
[__] missile to get him down he
refused to go down
that kid's [__] anxiety that's his
nickname anxiety because he kept coming
at him
taking punches to the [__] head that
kid must have a tremendous headache
today
what were your feelings on that fight we
were lucky enough to talk to him on
yesterday's mma junkie radio
uh chris moutinho and i thought he was
going to be like really really lumped up
but he wasn't as bad he almost looked
like he did on saturday he took a lot of
shots joey
he was picking three to dish out one but
he was never backing down
he kept pressing forward he never ran
out of gas in fact o'malley's the one
that kept looking up at the clock
where's the clock when's this round
gonna end because he started getting
tired at the end of the first
moutinho was hitting him with leg kicks
and then
started throwing some punches i think he
should have stayed with the leg kicks
and he told us the same thing
because o'malley's had problems before
with his legs you know he's tall and
lanky so he's a little shaky
um but you know either way at the end of
the day o'malley put a beating on him
and her
probably saved them from getting
completely iced but that's one hell of a
debut you know 10-day notice
to go in there on the on the main card
of
the best-selling pay-per-view of the
year you know and one of the
best-selling pay-per-views of all time
you got the green hair going so
everybody knows who chris moutinho is at
this point
for sharing fight of the night with with
o'malley so i saw that i was really
happy for him
can invest in himself and get better
before the next one he might drop the
flyweight though he told us
he's uh he's tougher than [__] death
that kid and he did take
a lot of punches to the [__] head i
mean that could be brain damaged
10 years from now whatever but you know
what you can't think about it like when
you're a fighter you just got to go in
there and let the pieces
fall where they made look i'm a [__]
comic and i got brain damage from doing
[__] k you never know you know what
i'm saying
it could be a punch to the head a
[__] microphone a bombing
you don't know what the [__] it is but
it was he was great
i was very happy for him i'm i when i
ready got the fight of the night
and 75 grand it's like i always say the
universe takes care of you if you do
your job you know so
the universe took care of him that night
the second
fighter the pay-per-views are usually 50
000 sorry sorry the bonuses are usually
50 000 but they
bumped it up to 75 the fighters spoke up
during the fighter meeting i think they
realized
hey this is a big show dana bump it up
so he got an extra 25
g's um but yeah usually it's only 50 but
he got 75.
damon lift the rock yeah and you know
what let me tell you something
um you ever watch um kate fear he almost
looked like max katie remember when max
katie got jumped
in the park last week i watched it for
like a minute
me and my wife watched it for like two
minutes it was on one night last week
the
robert de niro on i hadn't seen all the
[__] years
good movie but uh no he was a great
he did great and i'm really proud of him
and
he definitely made a fan out of me you
know i've always loved
sean but i didn't think uh i'd see
anything like that little [__]
monster from south boston or wherever
the [__] he's from
i wish him a lot of success and i want
to see him fight again
soon and get his [__] together because
he's going to be it's like looking at a
young charles oliveira
you know that's when i when i look at
those guys it's like
you're looking at a guy the ufc is gonna
[__]
you know just keep throwing in there
he needs to get about eight or nine
fights under his belt and then he'll be
[__] champion you know if he looks at
it in a three or four year or five year
window
so it was really good i i had a good
time with the car and i didn't
the only prelim i watched was carlos
conduit
that's the only one that's when i got
home i was out you know with the family
with the girls so
i didn't get to watch any of the other
fights
griffin went after him early and conned
it i think it was a five round fight
con did it comes back but he just turned
it on too late you know and and uh he
had taken a little bit of early damage
so
now he's not with greg jackson anymore
condon
uh i think i thought he was
i didn't see him there jackson doesn't
seem to corner as many fighters
and i think a lot of them now that they
make a lot of money branch off and do
their own camps and like one of the two
maybe winkle john
shows up and that's about it it's like a
lot of them are
starting to slow down a little bit with
the travel and coaching and
so i know jackson slow down a little
good
good good the second fight i want to
talk to you about one fight i bet
that i told you i was gonna bet was
gilbert burns against uh wonder boy
uh good fight a little slow you know i
bet gilbert i
you know just had a funny feeling that
gilbert was going to take him down even
though
he hadn't been taken down that much
before in his career
so i got lucky with that one what are
your thoughts on that fight
so that one was one we agree with as
well and we went against the grain
burns was the underdog here's the deal
with stephen thompson is is he's just
a difficult puzzle to solve because he
moves around and keeps the space
you know in between you and him and he
has
here's his biggest talent he is not
afraid to be boring he doesn't care
about the booze
he doesn't care if you go man you only
threw 25 strikes the whole fight
he doesn't care to be in slobber
knockers you know
or or those types of fights he's
strategic he's a chess player
so to beat him you got to realize you
got to be in a boring fight and that's
why this fight didn't really pop but if
you're a hardcore purist
you had to appreciate what burns had to
do you know occasionally burns through
some punches
and then he also got tagged so things
were evening out but where burns is way
better than him is jiu jitsu and to get
there he needed to wrestle
so he was doing these shots from like
far away low singles
and all he was trying to do is just get
attached to thompson's body somehow
so that he could then kind of work his
way into a you know
either drop them uh or take them down
you know traditionally or hip toss them
anything but just tie them up
because once they're separated that's
where thompson's money
you know what i mean so i knew this
fight was going to be boring and
strategic
but i thought burns would be able to put
his ego to the side and come up with the
type of game plan to
to just to just do that to do exactly
what he did on saturday be boring
but be the guy that's so difficult to
beat you know i
i love uh mma and i
always hated like i i became a fan
of the ufc and my first five years as a
fan
i enjoyed not gambling on it you know
what i'm saying like i enjoyed it
and then when they started blowing up
the gambling side of it
you know this line whatever then you
jump on
the wagon but at first i was a purist
you know
i love wonderboy i think he's a great
fighter
you know i hate when people put down
karate people like i [__]
it bothers me to death when people like
well he's taking karate
it's not going to do nothing for him on
the street that it helps you in a way
it does something for you teaches your
timing it teaches you a bunch of stuff
you know so
it was hard to bet against him but i
looked at the fight for what it was
thompson's getting up there in the years
gilbert's a little hungry
you know he lost for a championship so
now
he's a little hungrier so maybe if i'm
right maybe he'll pull out the win and
he did it wasn't a fancy win it wasn't
flying through the air there was no new
chucks or nothing
but he got the [__] win and that's
all that mattered you know it was a
great
i thought it was a nighter the mexican
girl had heavy [__] hands
you know yeah the little piling guy you
know
i felt bad for greg hardy i thought he'd
do a little better than that
he got knocked out you know uh obviously
tia doesn't give a [__] i guess somebody
put
hot sauce in his in a shoe and gave it
to him that poor bastard
who the [__] would drink out of his shoe
that's like eating a crackhole
his [__] you know who would drink out
of a [__] shoe
i mean what the [__] is wrong with you
but if that's what it takes to knock
people out
[__] it drink whatever they give you out
of your shoe but then somebody put
pepper in their
shoes and hot sauce
sausage and now girls and i were doing a
viewing party
he said that ty looked away it's not
like the guy was trying to be sneaky
he actually had it kind of like looking
at him like do you approve
but it's all happening so fast as he's
exiting the arena and i guess ty looked
away but
in the end he starts to do it along with
the beer and homeboy's drinking out of
the shoe and next thing you know
you see some orange or bread come out of
his mouth but he didn't look pissed
he was so happy you know he was so
primal at that moment i think he just
thought out you win something you lose
some with these damn chewies
but uh yeah you know he climbed a fence
and did his shoe he did a few and then i
think
one guy from the second level just
poured an actual beer in his mouth
i was laughing my ass off i was laughing
my ass off what do you call it a shoei
chewy yeah that's [__] crazy
i wouldn't even drink out of my own
[__] shoe what's happening let me
wait a minute if you do a proper shoei
with them if you're in a setting where
there's not thousands in the arena and
all that stuff
and it's just you and him supposedly
you're supposed to spit
in the shoe before he pours the beer can
you believe that
that's once if i ever do a shoei i'm
definitely leaving that step out
but i think i'd rather do justin poise
hot sauce than someone else's spit
but that that's what they say makes a
proper shoei i'm telling you man they're
mossy fighters that do them shoes are
nasty dogs
so that's an australian thing yeah
where is he from australia oh i thought
he was like uh
uh you know samoan yeah he's got a
little bit of the polynesian look but i
mean
he flies the flag so i think he's
australian
his background might be one of the one
of the other polynesian islands perhaps
but
he's australian a [__] chewy i can
see if you know the person and you know
the person doesn't have
foot fungus and [__] for you to drink
out of a shoe
but i'm not walking out of a [__]
octagon and just going to take
somebody's converse
size 13 converse and drink from the
[__] bottom that's just not gonna
happen that's
that's just [__] not good no bueno
you know what i'm saying no [__]
bueno
goes uh i don't know what happened but
during that watch along
they egged him on and his girlfriend
walks in and gives her
gives him her uh her shoe
and he actually goes pour the beer he
actually did a chewy in the middle of
our show
and uh out of her shoe so it's his
girlfriend
um but i'll give him this not one drop
came down on him he actually drank the
whole beer
out of it so he was really really good
but then i told him i go hey make sure i
thought i saw a little corn pad in there
and he almost started gagging it was so
funny we were last
laughing our asses off on saturday um
but yeah we had a good time with it i've
yet to do it but ghosts can honestly
we can honestly say he popped his cherry
now a hot chick i'll drink out her
[__] shoe
you follow me like some hot chick that's
got like a heel
you know what i'm saying she doesn't
it's a high heel you know she doesn't
live in them and [__]
yeah i'll drink out of a [__] woman's
heel that's not that bad what's the
worst thing a woman could step on you
know what i'm saying
but as men i know where my feet have
been they're [__] disgusting
i don't even [__] bite my toenail you
know nothing i don't do nothing
i'll bite my fingernails when i was a
kid but never disgusting your [__]
feet so
i'm not down with the [__] shoeies
okay [__]
but uh now let's talk about the main
card and what
so for the night i had gilbert burns
i had the over 1.5 rounds
okay and i bet dustin poirier for 25
bucks i won 61 on draftkings
i thought i thought that i didn't really
want to bet
uh poirier heavy heavy
i thought that conor was going to come
out you know throwing heat
and maybe knock him out in the first
round or whatever i didn't know what to
expect
once the fight started i saw what
direction it was going
and it kind of broke my heart a little
bit you know even though i bet
dustin to win i wanted a little life
out of connor like i wanted to see what
he could really do
it was just 25 bucks it's not gonna
break my [__] heart
but what i saw was just really [__]
sad you know
and what i saw after the fight and
doing it was really [__] sad what are
your thoughts on it as uh
mma junkies lead [__] man over there
well so i thought that conor would be
able to figure it out he made the
adjustment in the nate diaz fight
the second time everybody kept saying he
doesn't have the cardio to go and he
wound up going this whole 25 minutes
with ney diaz and i remember after the
first ds fight he said you know what i
throw so much
into every shot into every kick that i
expend too much energy so i need to like
manage my energy bar you know i got to i
got to be careful here because these
fights can go a little bit longer
and that's what i thought he was going
to do with poi a was just be more
efficient
more tactical and also have an answer
for that calf kick that really slowed
him down
you know six months ago uh but he came
out very aggressive with his own set of
kicks
you know he must he must have tattooed
uh
poised kick poi style like about a good
five times
and then he kept following it up with
that kip that front kick as well
he missed wild well he had a one time
poiye said and i saw him hit him one
time pretty solid but
i thought he hit him more in abu dhabi
um it's just that poise looked so
comfortable joey the kicks were coming
at him and he'd kind of like block him
and then he'd kind of look at him like
no
and then a couple shots like this and he
looked so calm his breathing he seemed
composed
he seemed confident and the game was in
slow motion which is something i
remember michael jordan say is
for some reason when the game is on the
line everything's in slow motion to me
and that's why i'm able to
to i guess execute and that's what it
looked like to me for dustin poirier
whereas conor
the panic setting in you know because
usually by now when conor hits someone
that person's starting to hunch over
or you know starting to bleed or
whatever and it wasn't happening poise
started
answered with like a four-piece combo of
his own connor didn't like it
and next thing you know their bodies are
attached next thing you know he gets the
dumbest idea which is to put his arm
around
and try for a guillotine you know and
most of those guillotines
don't work some do but when have we
known conor to be a guillotine machine a
sub machine we we don't
and poise pops his head out and then he
started raining down them elbows
so regardless of that kid's leg breaks
or not i just think round two
right the end of round one was the
beginning of the end and i think in
round two poi
was probably going to light him up at
some point conor still would have come
off that stool
he would have some firepower and poise
would have to you know miss a few of
those
i haven't missed a few of those you know
to get his offensive going but by then i
think poirier had proved that
he just has an answer for connor's
tactics
i'm happy you said that first and i
didn't say that first
so nobody will [__] get pissed off i
i didn't think
he would come out in the second round
with an answer to boreata
you know they're speculating all this
that i guess he said he had plenty of
fire in him or whatever
i don't see it i i just don't don't see
it at all
i saw him slowing down i saw his
confidence
uh drop a little bit and then they
called the fight
and then what the tirade that happened
on the floor
was just uh it was [__] crazy you
know and i
that's when i felt really bad that's
when i was like this could be over for a
while
you know what is going on with this kid
you know what is going on with him the
last three outings have been [__]
hard
he's gotten mauled pretty much the last
three fights it's like he's not
even been on the thing i i thought he
was going to go after the poirier fight
and really do some soul searching and
come back and even just forget [__]
pory let's do this right
let's start you know with the number
five guy let's work ourselves up
you know let's eliminate everybody one
at a time boom every six months whatever
you know get into a [__] draw
get into a a a rhythm
and then fight poorie when you're ready
and then sail off into the sunset you
know like a two-year window i was giving
him
now he's done for a year this is a year
that you're gonna be away for you know
uh poirier is just gonna get stronger
charles oliveira is just gonna get
stronger
there's a couple guys that are on their
way up there's a couple guys on their
way down
but i just don't see connor coming back
and catching up
and it's i think he's a great fighter
and i've seen great things happen before
but i think it's going to be tough for
connor after that one year
you know i agree that's a
terrible injury to come back from and
there's some killers that are waiting
you know waiting for him like chandler
and gaitsy so even if poi
because poise is going to move on to
somebody else so that's charles o'hara
he's going to fight for the title now
knowing the ufc they're probably going
to
try and figure out a way where they can
come back and do the fourth fight dana
white's already said in the table for it
but would it really be fair for conor to
come back and do part four if poised
champ
i don't want to disrespect oliveira but
if poise beats
oliveira does conor just walk into a
title fight because
fight three number three didn't have a
resolution
i don't think that's fair to gaiji
makashaf chandler
um daryush you know he's won like six
straight so there's a lot of killers
there that are waiting you know and
yeah and they need shots so what i think
he needs to do is take a fight kind of
like when he took cerrone now i don't
want to disrespect cerrone because he's
had a great career but cerrone's kind of
on the tail end
so maybe if he wants to do something
like that get somebody whose name
pops you can sell some tickets but you
can gauge what you're where you're at
and maybe get your confidence
maybe el kokui he's lost a few maybe now
it's time that you mixed it up with
ferguson
see where you stand you know and and if
you can get that win
then hey throw connor in versus poise
for part four
now that's what everybody was saying on
fight night no there was no resolution
he broke his leg
but now that we're investigating it a
little bit and watching the the videos
you're seeing that you know that leg
kick that he was throwing to the time
to to the thigh remember when i said he
would also come up right up the middle
they're showing evidence where poise was
blocking it with his elbow right
whatever
he cracked the tibia he cracked it there
um
you know cormier said something about
daniel cormier said something about one
of the kicks came up short and that may
have added to it
but i saw him block a few of those and
that's why when he stepped
that bone just went you know at that
particular moment and that's a defensive
technique
so you got to give poor yeah the credit
that he actually stopped them you know
he actually stopped them via tko
um but but you know they're not gonna
look at it that that way and they're
gonna paint it another way because
obviously
mcgregor is a money-making machine and
that's the only thing the ufc cares
about and how quick we can get them in
there when he's ready
straight into a title fight but i would
say if they took a risk and putting them
in there against cerrone then find
another lightweight who has a name
put them in there build them up at least
give them the one fight it's good for
him too
and then maybe and then see where he's
at
and then maybe give him
dustin gloria like i said it's a year
away guys
it's surgery was sunday you know
you figured 90 to 180 days i mean i just
got my knee done
i'm [__] 58 years old i'm an old man
and it was six months ago and i still
i can't [__] you know do a full 440
you know what i'm saying but i could
ride a bike i could walk fast
it takes time you know it takes time and
that's on the [__] leg you have to
kick with it
you have to step on it you have to
wrestle with it so you want to
strengthen that as
much as [__] possible before you go
back in that [__] octagon so i'm
looking at a year
11 months to a year you know 13 months
that's what i'm the window i'm looking
at
and if you think of where the ufc was a
year ago people are moving fast you know
people are still training people are
still
you know let's see where we go but my
my heart goes out to conor mcgregor's
you know training camp whatever the [__]
his leg
and my heart goes out to dustin poirier
for being a [__] champion of
champions
that's it that's basically handling it
with
class he said i hope he gets home to his
family you know i just don't have that
type of evil in me
but he did say connor just crossed the
line he called his wife a hoe
and uh you know implying things with the
dms and just not letting it go
you know i wasn't too sure about this
whole death thing or whatever he was
saying
um i you know i always say i think
sending someone out on a stretcher is
enough but i guess if you want to go
down the route of the morgue
or you know a coffin whatever sounds pro
wrestling-esque wrestling
at that point to me but i think conor
just like i say
he's having this like meltdown oh you
know um
as a human being you know not just as a
fighter but i think as a human
being and i think he really needs to
take a look at it and the only one
that's going to be able to put him in
his place
or at least talk to him i think he's
going to be a contemporary like a
colleague
even a former fighter like a tyson or a
duran or someone
sit him down and go listen we all lose
we all
no longer become the man but you can
you can get back there you know if you
do the right thing
um but you seem to not have a grip on
reality here you know everything seems
to be some sort of an excuse oh habib
did this
oh poyet did that you know where i
wasn't at my best
man we ain't trying to hear that the
rest of the way he i think he thinks
that we
basically believe every word that comes
out of his mouth we love him to death
he's clever he's witty
a lot of times he's right in his
predictions you know but
you know the rest we put we all put our
pants on the same way you know what i'm
saying and so a lot of us sit there and
we just don't gobble it all up and um
he think i think he needs to to figure
that out you know and um
once he does like he's like he's done in
other fights where he's shown humility
he usually comes back pretty strong but
right now he's still like in this
i don't know this stage of just not
being able to believe that someone else
has skills like he does
you know i watched uh the one presser
i watched the thursday not the weigh-in
but when he showed up with the suit and
threw the kick
and i remember when he threw the kick a
couple people hit me up on twitter and
said bet the farm on dustin
you know khan is at it again it was just
like they saw right through the kick and
um the behavior has been very weird
the last couple months i mean we've
always had a crazy connor and
that's what makes them conor mcgregor
the bus smacking the old man at the pub
you know all that crazy [__] but this
one started when
dustin just reached out and asked him
about the money
you know what happened to the money for
the charity
uh you know he took offense to it and
the hillbilly started and all that [__]
and uh
i was like jesus christ what the [__]
happened he was such a gentleman
for the last fight and then when i saw
him on the floor with rogan
it wasn't i'm not mad at him i don't
give a [__] you know
it's not my life but he just didn't look
good
and trust me i've gone off on people's
wives i said some shitty [__]
but uh they've been when i was
at a bad place in my life you know
so i kind of see what the [__] is going
on here
i wish whatever he's seeking you know he
finds
and i wish that uh maybe this break
will let him see what he wants to do
with his life
you know man you make a hundred million
dollars 200 million dollars
it's tough to get punched in the [__]
face it really is
it really is it's a little tougher to
get punched in the [__] face
once you get comfortable it's tough you
know a lot of people work better with a
gun to the head
but maybe he's going to realize this is
behind
him now you know it's too much pressure
on him to come back
it's too much it's too you know he's one
and four now you know the last
whatever he is one in three the last
couple fights and
you know i mean come on that
people were impressed with the
mayweather thing i i wasn't
you know i thought he carried him for a
couple rounds you know
i mean it's just it's been it's like a
bad weed it's like a rose that started
out as a rose then it became a [__]
weed it went into a different direction
so
i uh wish him well you know i'm looking
forward to oliveira against dustin
poirier that
looks like a [__] great fight i mean
my dick is hard for that fight and
uh that's it we'll realize
we'll see in six to eight months what
goes on with conor mcgregor
what's happening what's the state of mma
for the summer what are we doing for the
summer
yeah um do we have any great cards on
the line for the summer i mean i don't
even know what the [__] going on
the next big pay-per-view is amanda
nunes against juliana pena so pena came
up through the ultimate fight i'm sure
you remember her the venezuelan vixen
she faces amanda nunes the women's goat
um
and this is coming up in august in
houston texas they're back in houston
it's easier for the ufc to get regulated
there right now so things
the states start opening up um because
they were just in houston you know and
usually they don't go back right away
but
that's the world we're in right now and
then the main event is surreal gone
uh who defeated alexander volkov a few
weeks ago undefeated
uh heavyweight out of france he faces
the black beast derrick lewis
for the ufc interim title which makes me
synthetic
because and ghana is the undisputed
champ he just wanted three months ago i
don't know why the hell they're doing
under uh an interim title it makes no
sense it's not like in ghana who's
injured
but the ufc loves to promote title
fights of some sort
which they got one with amanda but
apparently maybe amanda doesn't sell as
well so that's why they got to do this
who knows um but that that's the next
big set of fights that's coming up but
you got
volkanovsky versus ortega you got al
james sterling versus peter yan they're
gonna run it back
um and then i think eventually in ghana
is gonna face the winner of this fight
so there's some really good ones that
are cooking now when jon jones is going
to return i don't know
he seems to want a lot of money and the
ufc is not caving
he's a heavyweight now uh blejovich is
fighting tashera
i think that's an october fight that's a
good fight so
there's basically most of the title for
most of the champions have
some sort of an outline mourinho just
won so we don't know who an opponent for
amazing
but look look for him to be a big star
he just make the president of mexico
he's the first mexican-born fighter to
to you know to win a ufc title and you
know the mexicans love their combat
sports they love it
they love it and they got to do a card
down there to really see what
[__] he's saying fernandez from
mexico you know because he's charming
you know what i mean he kind of
comes off and he admits that i'm kind of
nerdy man i love legos
but boy can he can he fight he can fight
he can
you know so uh i think the ufc is in a
really really good place you know
bellator started up again they got their
you know uh their promotion going again
they got a nice big fight coming up at
the end of july
patricio pitbul frady who's a
featherweight and
lightweight champ he faces aj mckee uh
undefeated fighter who's antonio mckee's
son but that's a fight that a lot of the
hardcores are looking forward to so
it's going to be a really really good
summer we just lost fury versus wilder
it was going to happen here in vegas
fury got covered
um but man if you're a combat sports fan
now's the time
you know there's just a lot going on and
i think now boxing and mma
and bare knuckle everybody's got some
love and respect for each other and
there's
it's no more of a territorial thing you
know right now i think everybody's
really really
becoming fans of the other sport as well
so combat sports is really really
booming how many days a week is mma
junkie on now
mondays and thursdays noon easter 9 a.m
pacific we're down to two days a week
because now we started doing a little
bit more of like what we're doing now
zoom you know a lot of these types of
interviews with fighters from all over
the world because it was cool to be on
two days uh two hours a day
monday through friday but what happens
is you're locked into that two-hour
window
and everyone wants video people consume
you know a lot of content on their phone
that's one thing
and then two you know you got
worldwide champions you got whitaker in
australia uh
style benders in new zealand you know
you got the uk
fighters and sometimes that two-hour
window just wasn't convenient you know
it was the middle of the night so right
now building a studio at home
slowing down and doing more videos kind
of allowed us to spread our wings you
know but we're still doing the show good
man i'm happy i got to get you on today
i'm happy you made time for me today
brother
i've been wanting to get you on for a
while and i wanted to promote a
talk about a good card and this last
card was great you know i know a little
bit about the ufc but you're the [__]
specialist
so i just wanted to get you on the joint
to let people know you [__] are
still
rocking over that mma junkie
mondays and thursdays brother uh it was
a blast being on anytime you need me man
i'd love to chop it up you know i love
talking mixed martial arts
um any sport i'm one of them guys though
that follows any sport
and sometimes i think that might be a
distraction to my
to my own craft i guess because the
sport's growing
and um you know a lot of my colleagues
man they're
they're just so sharp and they know so
much and we have great writers
you know and sometimes i'm like am i
stranded too much to soccer and football
and
you know not remembering every single
fight every every single detail of every
fight but i think i think it's because
now i'm in my 50s and i'm
i'm slowing down a little bit too but i
i can definitely uh
tell you what's going on with the big
fights we're all slowing down a little
bit i love you
brother keep me posted and uh
i'll check in with you from time to time
like we usually do and talk about
the world of ufc and mma and what comes
with it you know what i'm saying
for sure all right we're six weeks away
from the nfl
two weeks away from training camp so
you'll be even more [__] good
stadium the raiders fans are gonna be
into town it's not my squad but
i can't wait vegas is just popping with
a new sports hockey team now a football
team they say an nba team is on its way
as well
so yeah i can't wait for football season
well we'll be in touch
before football season i love you
brother have a great day and thank you
for calling the joint
all right thank you joey take care thank
you brother stay black
we're back you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed
george from mma junkies interview
we just shot this [__] it was really no
big interview we just covered the three
fights
and uh the mcgregor situation like i was
saying before you know
i'm a fan i'm a fan of the [__] ufc
i'm a fan of carlos conduit
i'm a fan of [__] the mexican chick
i'm a fan of
sugar shawn you know you're a fan of
these people and you watch them and you
when you pay to watch them it's like
when you coming to see me you want to
see me 100 [__] percent right
when i see conor mcgregor or dustin or
sugar or [__] great heart whatever
whoever the [__] it is i want to see
them at their best
i'm not cheering for them you know
that's why i was telling george
about the gambling for years i was an
mma purist i just
enjoyed watching the ufc and not betting
on it me and ari would go to the fights
and we'd bet a dollar two dollars with
somebody in the [__] audience we'd
have the good seats
and we'd better 20 or something but
that's different
the best the first bet i put in the ufc
and it broke my heart
was frank yeager against sean shirk me
and my wife better when we went to ufc
and it broke my heart because i wanted
to be like a virgin in the ufc but then
once they started adding lines and
you know i think the second fight i bet
was conor against diaz
and the rest was [__] history you
know i like betting the fights
i enjoy it but uh i'm a fan and that's
why i wanted to do this podcast today
about what we saw
on saturday night it was very [__]
sad and it was uh
sad for a guy like me to see this kind
of stuff you know
uh you watch the fights and you're like
[__]
you know i want to watch five rounds i
want this to end right you know it's
like watching anderson silver break his
leg or
the guy from long island breaking his
leg exactly the same way years later
you know when you see a fluke [__]
accident but that's not you know that's
what happens in the sport
what concerned me the most was his
behavior and
you got to ask yourself why is a rich
guy like this
acting this way you know um
he lost he's always humble in defeat you
know
but this one wasn't good and uh i saw
some things that were a little
disturbing
and i know you did too you know i mean
even if you're a kind of fan
i know that this fight you looked at and
you're like you know what this
is uh a little not for me
so i'm happy we clarified it
uh i hope he gets help i hope that
whatever is eating at him that he
[__] sees it because
when they throw that much money on you
you're young you don't [__] see it
you know
you don't know whether you're happy what
the [__] to think
you think that money is your happiness
and i get it i [__] get it you know i
was
32 at one time i was 20 once i thought
that
oh i get money and i get a boat and i'll
get [__]
it don't work that way i wish it did you
know i'm saying
it don't work that way you know uh money
doesn't buy happiness at all in fact it
puts a lot of [__] pressure on you if
you're one of those [__] people
just live your life be happy and enjoy
what the [__] you're doing
speaking of enjoyment don't forget this
friday
laughing gas comes out at the ice cream
shop
on ventura boulevard in [__] studio
city
i love these guys this is uh they've
done a great job with me before
you know i've been dealing with them
when they were urban trees
so i knew they would take care of me the
reefer is tremendous it's like [__]
i'm gonna cut it for you and show you
this is mikey sack i'm giving them oh
[__]
the sacks are tremendous
oh oh wait till you smell this [__]
oh [__] boom
laughing gas boom oh
[__] boom laughing gas
friday 4 20 boom
tremendous it smells funky
and it's gonna [__] your world up you
understand me
no more [__] [__] nothing but high
high
it's called laughing gas and it's only
available
at the ice cream shop and then we'll go
to other stores in southern california
and then we'll go to vegas then we'll go
to colorado
then we'll go to jersey and then we'll
go to new york this is all we're [__]
pushing at you today okay
you understand me [__] laughing gas
at laughing gas on instagram you're
gonna [__] love it
listen i hope you enjoyed the podcast
today
i hope you enjoyed the fights i hope you
enjoy what we're doing and what we're
trying to do here
don't forget to go to at laughing gas to
find out little details about this
we're gonna have some shirts coming out
the whole [__] thing it's a great
[__] bag
it's great [__] weed and you're gonna
love it laughing gas
at the ice cream shop i want to thank
you guys for supporting us supporting
patreon
and for just [__] being here i'm
happy i was able to do this you have no
idea
what these [__] gums feel like it's a
[__] nightmare but
you guys are well worth it i love you
[__] have a great weekend
and we'll be back monday tip top magoo
on the [__] 19th ready for you i love
you [__] now
for a word for my [__] sponsors jack
stay black are you bad [__] i
want to thank you again
for listening watching and supporting
uncle joey's joint before we leave i
want to thank our sponsors i'm going to
start
with on it let me tell you something
when it comes to supplements
on it is tip top magoo
whether it's alpha brain shroom tech
the ect oil i mean they just have so
many great products
you have to go to honor.com to start
you'll love it and the alpha brain
also comes in a powder now so you could
just pour it in water
shroom tech comes in a powder i mean
they're doing great things already on it
and now
they're releasing the black label alpha
brain tremendous
it's a refined formula that promotes
speed
and [__] focus for extreme
productivity you understand where i'm
coming from with this [__]
this will get you this like drinking 20
cups of [__] tea
doing blow doing all that [__] put it
together
and you feel great and with no guilt
that's what alpha brain will do for you
plus
it's got a money back guarantee hundred
percent
you could keep the [__] product when
somebody else does that in your world
that's when you know you're dealing with
a great company so go to honor.com right
now take a look at what they got
and press in joey or church and get 10
off delivered right to your
[__] crib
the joint is also brought to you by blue
chew listen
everybody wants to sling dick but nobody
wants to take blue chew
this is the way to go right now right
you're like joey what the [__] is blue
chew blue chew
is an online service that delivers the
same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis at a fraction of
the cost
you can take it any time day or night
and it's easy to [__] start the
process is simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com you talk to
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved boom you'll
receive the prescription within days
the best part is it's all on [__]
line
no doctor visits no awkward
conversations
no waiting online at the pharmacy nobody
breathing on your [__] neck while
you're
waiting online it ships right to your
door in a discreet package
the mailman doesn't even know you have a
problem with your dick now listen
you don't have to have a problem with
your dick to take blue chew you could be
a young guy that slings dick
but you want to put her out for a few
days you understand me
like you want to give her dick that she
won't be able to go to the gym for three
or four days
then bluetooth tablets are for you
they're made in the usa
and they're prepared and shipped
directly and it's way cheaper
than a pharmacy so you too can benefit
from
extra confidence when it comes down time
to give her
or him a stabbing blue chew can help
and they've got a special deal for you
you ready try blue chew for free joey
what are you talking about free i'm
telling you
free with promo code joey just paid the
five hours for shipping
that's it and your dick will be tip top
magoo
and you will tweet me and say joey i
[__] the brains out my dick is [__]
tremendous thanks to you
isn't that what you want to do that's
what i want you to do
so go to blue bluetooth right now and
try it for free
with promo code joey just pay the final
shipping
that's bluechute.com promo code joey to
receive
your first month for free and as always
i want to thank
bluechu for sponsoring the joint i want
to thank annette
i want to thank bluechu i want to thank
cbd lion
and i don't know who else we had on
monday [__] zip recruiters somebody
i love yous all thank you very much for
sponsoring us
thank you for having our back but you
guys at home thank you for listening
thank you for watching
and thank you for supporting do not
forget friday
right now before the [__] podcast and
go to at laughing gas
on instagram join we got different
things coming out
but the most important is laughing gas
at 4 20
p.m friday at the ice cream shop in
studio city
the rest is up to you you want to smoke
some good weed you got to deal with
uncle joey and the ice cream shop i love
you [__] i want to thank blue
chew
and honor again but most importantly
have a great weekend
and we'll be back monday the 19th tip
top magoo and my stitches will be
dissolved by then
i love you [__] stay black and
have a great weekend
there you go [__]
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
you